Coleman Wong came to the UK from Hong
Kong seven months ago eligible to come
here because of Britain's Colonial ties
he's part of one of Britain's fastest
growing communities he says he had no
choice but to move for my kids
educations
for a more stable life for freedom and
we have no other option
the last year has seen a net migration
increase of more than half a million
people
in spite of the record number of people
coming to the UK legally the government
says it wants to reduce overall net
migration insisting this year there have
been unprecedented circumstances causing
the rise
yet in the West Midlands town of Walsall
like so many other places they're
struggling to recruit workers
they are looking for people to do the
work but they have no one to do the work
now it seems like maybe British people
or UK citizens they don't want to do
that kind of work
there's a nod to Britain's shifting
migration history on most high streets
the brexit saw a huge move back to
Eastern Europe according to Romanian
shopkeeper Sile Dan
I think some of them left yeah because I
know I know some people they didn't even
apply for for status subtle status I
think that they decided to go back
because they didn't they didn't
uh think that they can survive here or
they can they can have a good life
but the impact on changing communities
isn't always easy to understand just ask
86 year old Peter Webster if this
Germany come onto the child an adult
sink we've accepted immigrants for all
hundreds of years but now it's getting
Beyond a joke
to what it is
Britain is balancing the quest to fill
jobs get the economy going and manage
its complex relationship with migration
Easter Holland Sky News